what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are jumping back into Batman
the white knight and here's the deal I
kind of okay so with the camera I like
having the camera and doing FaceTime
when I'm like explaining ideas but with
stories I don't really see a reason to
change that I don't really see a reason
to change the format that we currently
have at the moment I think it's kind of
cool because it allows the emphasis to
be on what we're talking about so much
as me just like explaining things so
with Batman the white knight this is
this is cool because what this story
does this is one reason why Shaun
Murphy's riding is so interesting as it
seems to follow like the traditional
standard of storytelling to a point in
the sense that we basically have like a
set of circumstances we're familiar with
right like the first third of the story
basically opened up oh really yeah I
guess the first third so far opened up
with like here's how Gotham City works
that's basically Batman as you're used
to him The Joker's a bad guy Batman's
chasing him around so on and so forth
pretty straightforward and then suddenly
it's the shift and it's well Joker then
become sane and he becomes a good guy so
the whole idea here had basically been
how does Joker as a good guy as Jack
Napier present a scenario that Batman is
actually more of a hindrance for Gotham
City
than a benefit and that's when he
started rolling him things like the
Batman devastation fund the idea that
when Batman went into a neighborhood and
things went awry though the property
values of the neighborhood would
absolutely plummet the wealthy would go
in and buy up all the property they
would wait for the for the Gotham City
government to use the devastation fund
or the emergency fund to basically fix
everything and then when the property
values went back up the wealthy would
sell them because of that like with all
these different things going on the
overall gist of this is that Jack Napier
has put out the narrative that while
Batman doesn't know him he's basically
an enforcer for the wealthy against the
poor and it's so cool because Bruce said
had no idea what was going on and the
picture that I've been painted by Jack
Napier was like it doesn't matter if he
doesn't know that's the way it is what
what what you think is going on is
irrelevant in the face of what's
actually going on and so the whole the
whole basis behind this was for Jack
Napier to basically say the only way for
Gotham City to actually become the city
that it wants to be to become this
beacon of what Batman is shooting for
this beacon of hope and light much like
metropolis it's for Gotham City to do it
on its own is for Gotham City to cast
off Batman because for everyone out
there who looks at Gotham City as a
potential place to live what they'll
always say is well what happens when
that man stops being Batman what happens
when he dies or he retires whatever the
case may be what happens when Batman
ceases to exist then what happens to
Gotham and I'm not moving my family to a
town that's going to go to pieces as
soon as Batman's
there's something along those lines no
one sees it as like a viable opportunity
for like the long-term and so that's the
basis of Jack Napier is to say like we
can read they have the city and make it
our own the issue with this is that
Batman is still on the fringe and Batman
still operating under the idea that
while Jack Napier is popping pills and
he's basically same now keeping the
Joker persona completely curved and in
the background the time will come when
he will become the Joker again and
Batman's eyes it's only a matter of time
where Batman had kind of jumped in and
basically stopped the Gotham City Police
Department and you know Nightwing and
Batgirl from capturing neo Joker in the
Mad Hatter well it wasn't his intention
to like allow those villains to go his
actions resulted in them going away and
so what this is done is as put Batman in
a position to where Nightwing and
Barbara Gordon are somewhat siding
against him now Barbara Gordon is still
kind of walking the middle ground here
Nightwing is on Batman's side in so far
that when the arguments made like Batman
needs to be rounded up and mid will
unmask him so everybody knows who he
really is they'll know that we caught
him legitimately Nightwing Stan's is
known enough you know we bring Batman in
but at the end of the day he keeps his
mask and it's kind of cool
because it's still really Nightwing
attachment to like the legacy of Batman
keeping that aspect of himself private
and so initially with Barbara Gordon
again she's on the fence here right like
like Barbara Gordon Stan's is like look
we Oh Bruce Wayne now in truth in this
story where we're basically given the
notion that like The Killing Joke
happened Barbara Gordon was shot she was
paralyzed she was Oracle and now she's
where she is now we are given those
little tidbits here in there but for
Barbara Gordon it seems to go much
deeper than the fact that like she was
shot by the Joker once and you know
eventually came back to health and you
know she was Batgirl all I kind of cool
stuff it's it's loyalty is what this is
loyalty to the ideology of what Batman
stands for and what Gotham City needs if
the ideology of what Batman stands for
that makes all this so significant and
so with that in mind like ultimately she
just kind of walks out and says look if
you guys are gonna do this I cannot be a
party to this whole situation and so
ultimately what you end up having is you
have Jack Napier and you have everybody
else kind of rounding up and then
suddenly coming up with ideas or trying
to figure out ideas on how to take out
Batman because the guy is quite
literally a one-man army
the various tools he has at his disposal
the various forms of travel they're
military-grade a person with a sniper
rifle on a building it's not gonna be
able to kill Batman by shooting him
through the glass in the in the front
window of the Batmobile
it wasn't designed
without purpose the one thing that it
can't deflect is an EMP because it has
electronic components it needs those
things the reason why nobody ever
thought about using an EMP before is
because of collateral damage
they would not only take out the
batmobile they would take out like
whatever vehicles were chasing after him
and they would take out power within
like you know a six block radius
and with Batman having his resources at
his disposal even if they took down the
Batmobile Batman would be able to make
his escape and may be no better off than
they were before and the City of Gotham
would hate them because they take him
down power to a portion of the city and
so they come up with this really really
genius idea Nightwing basically steals
this old analog style Batmobile that
didn't really run on the same level of
electronics of the current version does
it further correctly this is a throwback
to Batman the Animated Series which I
kind of like about this it's it's pretty
cool and it's pretty interesting to see
but what they end up doing is they
basically like chase them into a
warehouse and then suddenly it it's like
blank on all these lights which of
course blinds Batman and then they
detonate this EMP and the idea is that
because the warehouse is lined with lead
the EMP will only affect Batman's
Batmobile it won't affect anything else
around the city and with the older
version of the Batmobile that Jim Gordon
is driving running you know basically an
analog vehicle without all the other
digital components that currently exists
in the newest version his vehicle will
run along just as well as anybody else's
and that's what happens when is up going
on here his Batman is of course you know
blinded and taken by surprise with the
whole thing Jim Gordon fishtails Batman
swerves under him and sends him flying
into a pole and where Batman initially
makes his escape from from Jim Gordon
he's met by the arrival of Jack Napier
and this is awesome this is part of one
of the coolest moments in the whole
story because this is like the fight
scene from like they live right like
rowdy roddy piper versus that one black
dude who does the narrations for the
navy it's just a bare-knuckle fight
between Jack Napier and Batman and under
normal circumstances we would expect
Jack Napier to basically have his
backside handed to him quite readily by
the Dark Knight but remember Jack Napier
has been training here now this is where
I kind of think that that Shawn Murphy
fudges the numbers a bit Batman is the
culmination of like decades of martial
arts training Jack Napier doesn't have
anywhere near that level of training now
an argument could be made that like Jack
Napier was able to capitalize on Batman
being injured it's really the only
reason why Batman was in a weakened
state so on and so forth but we have to
believe that with all the battles of
Batman's fought over the course of his
existence as a superhero
all the life-threatening injuries he
sustained all the times that he pushed
himself to the limit and kept on going
that he would be able to overcome this
but
that's the beauty of this story being a
miniseries that's not in continuity
basically it's Shawn Murphy telling us
everything else you know throw it away
like throw it out and the fight between
the two of them is hardcore this fight
is is the culmination of just like years
and decades of Batman chasing after the
Joker so these guys are fighting with
their heart and soul every ounce of
anger every ounce of vitriol every ounce
of hate being poured into this this
physical battle the issue with this is
that Batman's injuries get the better of
him and Jack Napier comes out on top and
so what we end up doing is having Jack
Napier basically take the body of Bruce
Wayne directly back to Commissioner
Gordon everybody and they end up
throwing him into Arkham Asylum and
essentially intending to leave a minute
the issue with this is that before any
of this can basically happen we end up
having like this giant gun that was used
by neo Joker this giant freeze gun
that's fired on the city of Gotham and
what she does is right into the side of
several buildings send the Joker now
this is where things get really really
interesting this is actually where I
think Shawn Murphy goes a totally
different direction but it all sort of
ties everything in together Victor fries
for the most part in this story was just
a guy who's there and in the early
issues the question that had to be asked
was why is he here what this does is it
basically says like that his father was
the part of the Axis powers that Thomas
Wayne was part of the Allied powers and
the two of them basically crossed paths
when Thomas Wayne learned of the
cryogenics research that was being
performed by the father of Victor freeze
and where the US military industrial
complex wanted to use the father of
Victor freezes research for weapons use
Thomas Wayne wanted to use it for a
source of healing and Victor freeze
agreed with this idea using those things
to make the world a better place and so
because of this Victor freeze is just
kind of a guy who operated in the
background and seems to have like a
long-standing relationship with the
Wayne's insofar that he goes all the way
back to Thomas and where he spilled all
this information to Bruce he's spilling
all the information of Robert Gordon
right now the other half of this is that
the way that Victor freeze found out the
identity of Bruce Wayne was that when
Bruce Wayne was initially injured at the
beginning of the story and then showed
up back and then Alfred basically you
know Bruce Wayne woke up and Alfred was
in a chair dead and Bruce Wayne was
hooked up to the free technology which
had kept him alive what we know finding
out as Victor freeze was there that
Alfred essentially called him and said
like you have to come here you have to
help out you have to get Bruce Wayne
back on his feet offered sacrifices life
for that purpose but the promise that
Victor made at the behest of a dying man
was you cannot tell anybody the identity
of Bruce Wayne I'm not making this
request because I can I some
have the ability to enforce it I'm
making this request because you're an
honorable man and I know that you will
honor it Victor freeze goes through who
talked about his father you know Baron
von freeze he despised what is what his
father stood for he despised what his
father was about and that's why all this
is being done now the biggest downside
of this and the reason why this is so
cool is because Barbara Gordon showed up
here looking for answers finding a way
to like deactivate this freeze gun
Victor freezes responses my father built
it I don't know anything about it I
can't deactivate this thing for you I
can't undo this you're gonna have to
find a different way and so ultimately
she just ends up leaving no better off
than she was when she first got here and
so what we do is we pick back up with
Jack Napier and again this is where the
whole argument kind of comes to fruition
in the sense that like Jack Napier's
lost control of everything
Jack Napier took the quick and easy path
he just kind of walked into the
situation that in his hubris and in his
arrogance of believing he could conquer
the city of Gotham when he didn't take
into account is all the wild cards
characters like like neo Joker and
collateral damage and it's like that's
the one thing Batman always realized
that sure you can move this chess piece
here but if you do somebody else is
gonna move their chess piece there it's
not a game that's played where there's
no consequence and this is kind of Shawn
Murphy throwing into our face is this
idea that Batman walks a knife's edge at
every single time Bruce Wayne Dawn's the
cape and cowl and every single time he
goes out into the city of Gotham his
Batman he has to weigh the pros and cons
of every decision he makes and while
Bruce Wayne's intelligence allows him to
do that Jack Napier is a guy who's
popping pills to keep the Joker persona
at bay he is not Bruce Wayne and so this
is cool because essentially the argument
by a by a by Harley Quinn is you've
totally lost control the situation like
you spend so much time trying to develop
the Gotham anti-terrorist group you've
spent so much time trying to sit down
and try to be Bruce Wayne you never took
the time to realize that you cannot be
Bruce Wayne because you are not Bruce
Wayne and you cannot function in the
same capacity as Batman what is it
happening is you basically have Jack
Napier who essentially gives in he goes
and he meets with everybody with with
with the Gotham City police with the
vigilantes with with everyone here and
the questions asked what do we do she's
demanding the Joker what option do we
have
and Jack neighbors response is there's
only one option that we have and he
essentially allows his Joker persona to
cut loose and we end up seeing the
return of the Joker with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to come as
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch
you all later purse
[Music]